so new york state
since the first day has been really the
epicenter of the chronovirus outbreak if
any state needs the vaccine it would be
new york
obviously but here's the amazing thing
right now new york currently ranks 28th
in the united states in vaccine
distribution
there's a reason for that phil boyle is
a new york state senator he joins us
tonight to assess what's going on in new
york philba thanks so much for joining
us
why is new york which you think would be
number one 28th
well i think tucker because governor
cuomo was thinking about other things
you think if you think about the
chronology last march and april we had a
huge
first surge of covert here in new york
state and then the numbers went went far
down in july and august but we all knew
the vaccines were coming
and that's when the governor should have
focused on finding distribution sites
creating a real plan
for getting this vaccine these vaccines
out if you think about what was he doing
he was
creating a poster he was writing a book
he was arguing on another network
with his brother about who their mother
liked more uh he was not focused
on the distribution centers so you'd
think
and i think to be fair this would be
true in every state
that people over 70 would be first in
line
the older people are the more priority
they would be given that is not the case
in new york why
correct the governor is focusing on
health care workers
just fine front front line health care
workers however
they should be focusing on the most
senior among us i have constituents of
mine on long island
uh over 75 over 70 over 65 and they're
watching on tv
seeing people in florida driving up
getting the vaccination in their arm and
driving away
and they're asking me how can i go down
to florida to get the vaccine
these life-saving vaccines that's scary
and sad
well some people have driven to florida
in fact i know some driven from new york
or new jersey
to the state of florida they'll probably
just stay like
so many thousands of others phil i
appreciate you coming on tonight thank
you
thank you tucker